Ah, just a little mindful meditation to relax
the brain.
Man, this feels great!
Oh.
Eugh.
Mindful meditation is the latest cure-all
for, well, just about anything.
Do you want to eat better?
Cure your back pain?
Become rich?
Well, then close those eyes, take a deep breath
and...do nothing, really.
The news is full of headlines about mindful
meditation, and that’s not surprising since
scientists have been researching the practice
and coming up with some promising observations.
Some of which are really cool, like increasing
the grey matter in your brain cool.
But not everyone is sold.
A group of 15 psychologists and cognitive
scientists have published an article that
highlights the weaknesses in the current research
on meditation.
So what’s going on?
Is mindful meditation good for you or not?
Mindful meditation has its roots in Buddhism,
but was made popular in the West in the 1970s
by Jon Kabat-Zinn, a molecular biologist who
used the technique as a method to reduce stress.
Interest in the practice has particularly surged in the past 20 years in both the scientific community
and in the media.
And hey, full disclosure, I’ve tried it.
And it wasn’t in a temple or a church.
I went to a group meditation class led by
doctoral students in a medical center.
And it was good.
I felt a lot better.
So I was bummed to see this article about
the problems with mindful meditation studies.
And, man, there were problems.
The article points out that only around 9%
of the research surveyed used a control group
to account for placebo.
Less than 25% bothered to look for any negative
side effects of mindful meditation.
And a 2014 review of 47 trials showed no benefits
for substance abuse, aiding sleep, or weight
control, which is not great considering these
headlines about meditation helping with
substance abuse, sleep, and weight control.
But the real sticking point for the researchers, has to do with defining the term
“mindful meditation”.
And that’s because, well, there isn’t
one clear definition.
At least not in scientific research.
I mean a general way to describe it is directing your attention to the present moment without
any judgment or reaction.
Just being.
But that definition isn’t consistent across
all studies.
I mean sometimes there are definitions focusing
on your breathing, or how you’re sitting,
or what your posture is.
This makes comparing data from different studies
incredibly difficult.
On top of all this, researchers were also
concerned with how the media is reporting
on mindful meditation.
Most of the time, they’re lauding the practice
as a magic cure for all ailments.
So the researchers worry that overstating
the benefits of meditation could potentially
lead to harm.
Like, you probably won’t be able to meditate
away your high cholesterol.
That might deserves some traditional medical attention.
Now this doesn’t mean the researchers see
no benefit from mindful meditation.
They point out a couple of studies that have
encouraging data about relieving anxiety,
depression, and pain.
They also had no problem with the methodology
of a study that showed increased thickness
in the prefrontal cortex, which again, that’s
pretty cool.
So no one here saying don’t meditate.
It might just be helping your mental and physical
health.
Just have some tempered expectations while
doing so.
So, maybe we don’t know if meditation can treat drug addiction, but maybe a vaccine can?
Find out in this video, don’t forget to
subscribe and be sure to keep coming back
to Seeker for more videos.